I'm writing every hasidine Demon Slayer
to figure out who is the best one this
is gutomioka the current warahashira and
his water breathing style is like a
deadly river which can easily eliminate
demons all over the battlefield in fact
you is such a master that he even
developed his own secret technique.com
18 out of 20 points cool weapons you
used a standard nietzsiding Katana and
his swordsmanship is so refined that it
was even complimented by the upper Moon
3 so 15 points and the water hashira
also has some of the most impressive
Feats as he teamed up with tanjiro to
take out the upper Moon three turned his
blade a legendary red and was one of the
few to survive the final battle against
the demon king So plus 16 points for
Feats however even though his
personality is quite soft-spoken you
absolutely never gives up like when he
keeps fighting after literally losing an
arm plus 70 points for a personality but
his appearance is just a little bit too
basic and has always reminded me of
Sasuke so a measly eight points for
design which brings his total to a quite
impressive 74 points and the first place
for now